[Music]
i've always fantasized about being on
the show
family feud i loved watching it and i
know occasionally they'll have um
they'll do like a celebrity one that's
gross you can call yourself a celebrity
i know but well there are degrees of
celebrity um
and i've been asked now to do it they
asked me to do it i got really excited
agreed to it and then realized um
i i don't know if
i'll have a family to be able to do it
with
not not to say that i i know i won't
have my own family in time you know to
have a wife and kids and stuff but um i
asked my parents if they'd want to fly
out because it shoots in la
and they're in connecticut and uh but my
parents have a hard time saying like
giving concrete answers so they
basically said no but um i asked my
older brother damian if you would do it
and uh he just recently said no so i
think christian you're gonna come out
hopefully please i need a family i need
i'll do it there are four slides um
so i'm gonna ask friends i'm gonna
hopefully uh my friend togo uh and
tiffany just had a baby mazel so you'll
create a new family
uh yeah so i'll be part of your real
family and your fake family well don't
call it fake it's still real it's just a
different family and a lot of people you
know families come in all shapes and
sizes oh tell me more justin
um so this would be my like la family
who uh who's not afraid to fly it'll be
fun i can't wait i i really am looking
forward to it and um i hope you guys are
looking forward to the show because it's
about to start i had already started but
you know how we do it life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long who has gotten
really good at introductions
[Music]
with me as always is uh my a member of
both
families for me i'm excited i'm a little
nervous because i often get those things
wrong when they you know they pull a
hundred people paul
um
i don't often i don't always think with
like well here's what here's what's fun
about family feud is that it's a pretty
low stakes thing in that
if you don't do well and your team
doesn't win it's not the kind of thing
where
you should be
embarrassed you know it's not like
jeopardy or even wheel of fortune where
there's like
real skill and knowledge required to do
well family feud is more of a crap shoot
well this is just like how good are you
at like guessing survey answers right
and there is definitely skill to it i'm
not gonna discount that don't just are
you trying to lower the expectations
yeah i'm saying you shouldn't be nervous
about the possibility of losing because
you know it's it's it's like who knows
how people are going to respond to these
when we were kids we would like downplay
um how likely we were to win it's
something we call it confidence boosting
so like i'm thinking mostly with ping
pong we would do it like oh you know uh
i i stubbed my toe um so i i'm not
really into in perfect shape so you're
probably going to win you just like
lower the bar yeah the expectations i
guess we're still doing that yeah yeah
you know you mentioned wheel of fortune
i uh it's hard now to watch that because
that was grandma's you know that was her
favorite yeah and and i had this fantasy
for so long chris and i did a pilot with
um two guys from that from sony tv
shout out to glenn the glenn's and um
it was always my fantasy to um
to have her on to have her on wheel of
fortune she was so brilliant at that
show and like it's not an exaggeration
when i say that like let's say the
answer was to kill a mockingbird
there would be like
an o and like maybe a t yeah and she'd
be like to kill a mockingbird she would
get the whole thing from like two
letters it was like it was scary how
could she it was like it was a repeat
episode and she had seen it earlier
she's doing a bit and she was trying to
fool everybody and she had was um she go
she'd get a little like proud of it but
she didn't boast that much i mean she
uh
yeah she was really funny and jeopardy
too um smart lady uh why are we talking
about family feud well
i'll tell you why um whoever clicked on
this and happened to see the guest might
know this already because it's on the in
the description but our guest today is
the former host of family one of the
former hosts louis anderson
one of the funniest people
oh yeah he hosted one like the late 90s
yeah 98 to 2 000 was it actor richard
carne is that out and when he fit in
that's pretty good
i need
richard dawson was oh yeah we were kids
right and then oh yeah then there was
someone else and then
richard khan and then louis anderson and
now steve harvey yeah but there was
someone after before steve harvey too uh
oh wayne brady did he do it i don't
think so what was richard karn he was on
home improvement right but he always
he was wilson no oh no who's the guy
behind the video right you're an idiot
of course you're right um who played
once i'm an idiot not you uh i don't
know but he died i think
wilson i think
uh no he played uh tim the tool man
taylor's sidekick you don't have to call
you don't have to use his whole
name i'm i'm uh stalling so i'm trying
to think of uh richard carne's name uh
oh oh oh oh his name was uh uh uh hey
hey
who i'm trying to like spark your memory
did you do things like that like monkey
noises yeah yeah that's his name
that's a perfect name for him for that
character because you know what's funny
about richard karn on that show was he
was a little bit more um
kind of boring and like submissive and
like the straight man and like well gee
tim uh kind of he was a fun it was a
funny character yeah it was a good show
yeah it was i like that show
yeah well why are we talking about that
show tim allen may be future guests oh
yeah former uh co-star i haven't seen
him and i you know i don't think i've
seen tim allen
oh wait that's not true i did see him
and um
i didn't think he'd remember me so i
didn't say anything to him i saw him
years later anyway our show today is uh
not with anyone who had anything to do
with home improvement or galaxy
questions
family feud family feud yes louis
anderson so former host of the of that
show but obviously is a lot more than
that well he's like one of our great
comedians yes and i hadn't been aware of
him for a couple years until
the show baskets which christian i
watched religiously was uh i think one
of the funniest most brilliant shows so
if you haven't seen it you really should
it's uh it's so good we talk about it
today it's a show that flew under the
radar a little bit it never became super
popular but it is
so brilliant
and if anyone listening has not heard of
it do yourself a favor and check it out
it's so good zach galifianakis stars and
louis anderson plays his mother on the
show that's good context because we do
uh yeah we'll talk about it and how that
happened and um
and many other things he i just
really enjoyed him i really enjoyed
talking to him so i and i had never met
him so here we go my
first impression with the very funny the
very sweet empathetic but mostly just
really hilarious louis anderson
life could be a dream
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
hi
louie hi
how are you i'm good what a pleasure to
see you thank you see you how's
everything uh good what is that oh bowie
you have a bowie shirt david do i love
bowie
is this a good setup for where i'm
sitting
oh it's great you look great i love
oh that was this
artwork of uh one of my fans is that
from baskets yeah that's a an acrylic
painting it's a message and brought to
me at the show i was at oh it's
reforming and i just love that painting
made me feel good and it makes me
cheered up to have it behind me like
that i love it i like yeah i can't wait
to talk about
that role i can understand why people
were inspired by it but um i'm sure a
lot of people
rediscovered and discovered this whole
other side of you when you did baskets
what was that like to get that call
because i i had heard zach galifianakis
say that she just called you it was just
as simple as that louis called steve
levine and said can i get louis
anderson's number louis ck oh louis did
that's right that's right i'm on my way
to work at the plaza hotel downtown
vegas i had a show there
and i get a call
louie i go
louie
how are you because hardly ever with the
name louis i bet yeah louie to somebody
he goes i'm here with zach galfinakis
and jonathan chrysler the director and
brilliant yeah i love john he said
zach's doing a sitcom
would you play a part in it and i go
yeah
he goes would you play the mother
and i go yes
just like that and zach told me later he
was they were talking
and louis said to him well what does the
what does the mother sound like
and zach went ah
and louise said to him this is you know
i think there's a few stories but
louie said to him
well you mean like louis anderson he
goes yeah he goes should we call him
and that's and that's and they called me
and
about five months later three to five
months later time has all disappeared
for me but
um they said show up here in silmar
california to the christine house that
was the house we used during all the
seasons i went into the wardrobe and i
had a lot to pick from and i picked out
stuff i thought my sisters or mom's mom
would wear the wig was too small because
i have a giant head
so they had to cut the wig
i went in the makeup trailer and they
put the wig on and
i really shout just one scene
jonathan gave me a lots of room wow
yeah i said to him right before we shot
i go jonathan
i'm not going to change my voice i'm not
going to do a falsetto weird voice so
smart just do my voice
like another six months we got the call
that fx ordered 10 episodes and was
there any adjustment then louis from
what you were doing to when you began
shooting did chrysler say anything to
make any adjustments he never said
hardly anything wow yeah he always
here's what he would do he would do this
louise isn't doing anything with his
fingers bringing it down just subtle
smaller ah huh smaller i tried to put
him as much of my mom in it or my
sisters or people i knew
the one thing i did is when i got
dressed i left louie anderson in the
trailer
uh-huh i said louie you stay here
he said that to myself he said he said
fu
and i want to get i got to get over to
that craft service table
that must have been hard for him yeah oh
he was mad he was i tore the trailer
apart
and uh
but that was really important that i did
that what other attributes of your you
said you you a lot of that was your mom
and your sister i know you're this you
have a 10 siblings or i love it you're
the second youngest of 11. right 10 out
of 11. wow do they know that your
sisters and are they proud of that or
are they like wait a minute all my
sisters think it's them what was that i
mean specifically like what were they
what they were eating that the type of
smoking any of that it was more like
this
oh
uh-huh
oh i don't know you know that's my mom
uh-huh like i you know she influenced me
a great deal how are you mom oh i'm fine
how are you
and then when you knew my mom wasn't
doing well she'd go i go how are you mom
i'm okay i guess
i go what's wrong
ah i don't know
how long is this gonna take um
you know i go what's wrong well did you
hear about shirley
and you think to yourself i'm not sure
who surely even is
you know
but she goes early
and then she'd go you know her
yeah my mom doesn't know yeah
you know when you were little she bought
you those cute little cowboy boots
like 40 years ago yeah like 40 like you
know 50 60 years now but and she goes
she goes i go what happened
well she fell
and then she would look at me like i had
something to do with it
i go oh that's terrible and she go isn't
it though
i hope i don't fall louie what
i hope you don't either
wow and she laid there for three days
louie
and had her had her cat
not brought her kibbles and [ __ ] she'd
be dead right now
yeah i know you mean there's a there's
there's a part of always dread with it
yeah
like what are the ramifications for me
uh
and also there's like i know what you
mean there's like a part of it that um
that you've somehow contributed to this
yeah
you're the blame somehow
that's really funny i appreciate those
boots
what are yeah talking about so that's
what i loved about my mom and
midwesterners in general from
minnesota and
always have bad news
always will everything's fine
to hear about carl
no
they can't find him
oh
well where was he last no one knows
it's a shame isn't it i guess so
but it's not i love that stuff though
yeah
nuance me too that's what's great about
the character and nuance i love words
don't you yeah i love them yeah
and subtlety that that kind of subtle
difference is funny zack is like that
zach's brain is like that the way he
plays
a message from zach
i love zach i love him i love him you
know he he just we talked yesterday we
like each other
no you'll call me i never bug them you
know i just don't like bugging people i
figure they'll call me yeah you know and
some people go well you never call me
and i go i just want to bug you
i go you don't want me on your thing
calling you all the time i guarantee you
here's how people are doing our you know
when you grow up in the midwest what are
you up to today uh-huh
well i haven't really done anything you
haven't done anything uh-huh you're just
sitting around
you shouldn't really get something going
they'd love to get in your business yeah
yeah well i see zach can he can talk
about anything and and he's very untrue
no
oh i wouldn't i just tease it i'm
teasing is that the most fun to tease to
tease yeah and he's a good teaser he is
oh he's a horrible man that way yes he's
trying to look oh those are pictures of
people
what are you looking at those pictures
were behind you the little ones
oh these yeah of all the guests not all
of them but some of them uh and i had a
beavis and butthead oh and it sounds
like
some butthead i do too
i should be this and butthead uh that's
pretty have you oh you
you need to work with him he would love
you is mike judge
oh well mike would always throw some
louie anderson
stuff into
the king of the hill
bobby was a huge louie anderson fan
deli he goes i don't have the louis
anderson oh that's funny you know and
then he had a tribute wall to me or
something or it was just so beautiful it
really made me feel wonderful yeah
but mike made that's a beautiful cartoon
i thought so too speaking of animated
where we just pitched uh life with louie
to one of the streamers about bringing
it back oh that'd be great i love that
show bringing that family into the 20
yes is this the 2017th century 2017.
yeah yeah
no but to bring it to the current time
and
get more
you know make it kind of like
i'm not done with that show i did three
seasons i'd like to do some more i bet i
bet it and and that's the great thing
with some character on it uh i would
love it i just how i met mike i think
was doing some king of the hills i love
doing voices um not to keep going back
to baskets but something that i found
really beautiful and relatable about
your performance was that i hadn't
really seen that
i knew that person i i they were so
familiar to me in such a
lovely entertaining way and i had never
really seen them
represented on on screen yeah you know i
always tell people don't give up because
i got my dream part when i was 61. wow
wow i always thought i'd play my dad but
he turned out playing my mom
i think baskets was a big show that i
think other shows maybe got spurred from
it or some
you know because people started thinking
a little differently like thank goodness
for fx i
know because they took that chance on
this show i always said people say what
do you how do you think what do you
think about the show i go well it's not
for everybody
yeah but it's for everybody who needs it
you have no idea how many emails and
messages i got on social media about how
much better
christine made people feel and feel
hopeful my mom
had so much humanity she just had this
giant amount of
acceptance with people
you know like if the kids in the
neighborhood were not getting enough to
eat she would invite him for supper oh
wow
my dad would grumble he had an old
neighborhood in here and she go well
maybe i will she didn't like that
anybody was excluded just was a really
amazing humanitarian
she was a really a wonderful human being
who you would have loved
and then you would have had to say
eventually i gotta go now
because you're talking about every
single thing well you could find the
beauty yeah of the color of a desanti
bottle that was the whole that episode
oh yeah that was my mama in a nutshell
look at the blue on this well yeah
kid
kid kid look at that who's the kid oh
it's an expression louie uh look at the
blue on this bottle just put it in the
window that's like a piece of art glass
oh wow louie what a gift to be able to
imbue a character with that and have her
live on it through that oh my god this
is what it was like
it was her
winning every accolade you know i was so
happy because she could have been
anything i think
yeah yeah right i know those people yeah
and she had 11 children wow
wow 11 children and we all thought we
were the favorite but really jimmy was
we really knew jimmy was oh really what
number was he where was he in the order
uh let's see jimmy let's see i know him
so it's can't
ria i'm doing it age-wise can't rio
roger
mary
jimmy
shanna
sheila
billy
lisa
louie
tommy
wow with all those kids you would also
think for someone to have such a
positive outlook and such a buoyant
spirit
after i would think you know the weight
of the world would be oh
yeah wow i mean she had us even as tough
my dad was an abusive alcoholic so it
really made it 10 times worse
god how did you navigate that how did
she maintain that personality not only
with all those kids but like
in the face of
that kind of she fed us
that's true what kind of stuff would she
make
anything comforting uh-huh yeah why
don't i why don't i make up a beautiful
egg salad sandwich for you oh that
sounds delicious
don't you love a egg salad louie you
know what i like to do with an egg salad
sandwich louie i used to cut a little
celery and onion in it
i go
you know then you've got a crunch you
got the soft in the crunch louie and
then
um
i just
i use a little miracle whip i don't use
the mayo mayo doesn't make me happy but
the miracle whip it's a miracle louie
what if
if you were playing your dad you had
mentioned you thought you'd end up
playing your dad what is this thing huh
uh
justin
you're veteran justin uh no sir wow
that's all right kid yeah but i respect
tremendously respect veterans oh yeah
well where did you did you fight sir
were you in in did you see action you
want to see the scar
um it depends on where it is you kids
today
what do you know
anyway yeah you did drink around here
um my dad was a really very he was a
wonderful musician played trumpet and
coronet
with hoagy carmichael nope long before i
was born you know oh wow by the time i
was born he was a laborer
you know he had 11 kids he
was an alcoholic he
lost his way with the music music
because you can't make any as a jazz
even jazz back then you couldn't unless
you were hoagy right uh
anyway so what's that part of the
drinking do you think louis what had he
been drinking
a horrible i wrote a book called dear
dad they're letters to my father 10
years
after he died that really helped me
understand that my dad had it a million
times harder than i did wow he's a
person so yeah he was
there was a murder in his family and he
was split up he was put up for adoption
and he he was split up from his sister
oh and god lived with at a farm that
where they used them as a work hand and
because put up for adoption was comes
from this uh they put up the for the
congregation and whoever could take the
kid would take it
oh my god yeah and so like i had so much
respect after that i bet how therapy
never knew it was good oh my god that
book saved my life yeah you've written
four right um yeah and covered m must
have covered most of your life you must
have yeah yeah i mean i i the last one i
just wrote about my mom hey mom yeah
yeah and that really helped me a lot
with my you know like i wish i would
have been i always tell people if your
mom's still around become friends with
her and ask her all the things you won't
be able to ask her
why would what was her life gonna be
before you
yeah
who is she become friends with her what
were her dreams what were her yeah and
what and what have you done to
appreciate the
years of toil and
diapers and yeah spit up and
yeah hoop and pee and
yeah
when did you come to appreciate that
louie was it was an hour ago it was just
one hour ago oh wow it all kind of lined
up i go oh i'm glad i'm talking to
justin bieber oh good i'm glad i asked
this we could all go a lot smoother but
yeah i guess it's a it's an evolving
thing with me i keep doing it
keep peeling off the stuff and i i think
i'm better every day and the pandemic
has you know i keep running into myself
i don't know if that happened to you
yeah yeah you run into yourself and go
oh my god there you are yeah oh my god
i'm so sorry that i'm
you and you're sorry that you're me and
we should be nicer to each other when
you were writing the letters to your dad
what was the the thing um that you wish
more than the others that you could have
said to him directly i love you dad yeah
yeah
and you were a prick
yeah and i hate you and i love you and
i'd kill you but i don't want to go to
prison
but i forgive you
yeah and i would like to kill you
these letters started at people where i
wrote these letters about they did an
issue with me and suzanne summers and
and drew barrymore
adult children of alcoholics oh wow and
i had just started this book because 10
years before my friend jim guitar i
drove him to his father's grave in
duluth minnesota he read his letters
to his father and i said someday i'm
gonna have to do that ten years later i
wrote dear dad i started writing at the
summerfest in wisconsin when i was
performing
and i started writing letters to my
father and that became these letters
that i gave to todd when he was doing
the article about adult children and the
response i got
made me think
i was writing a different book right
then for simon and schuster about just
being a comedian
and i said i don't want to write that
book i want to write this book and they
said we don't want it but penguin
we went over to penguin and they wanted
it wow and that was a really good thing
i got 10
000
letters from my bed
and i still have them they're right in
the garage those letters life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
i need to ask you about uh coming to
america my only complaint louie was that
there wasn't nearly enough of you you
have to remember
that movie had a lot of things to answer
but
the thing about me that it did answer it
answered so you can't talk about it yet
but no no i know but yeah
it worked out i think we had some other
things planned and they didn't work out
and
imagine i mean craig did such a great
job oh it's wonderful
and then that craig is i mean
but it must be interesting for you just
because that was um
in terms of being able to look back at a
character and and your career i would
imagine that was an earlier job of yours
um
and just to a it must be a trophy all
the things that have changed and um
and how fun to get to revisit that too
it was fun sitting and talking with
eddie and arsenio in those chairs with
our names on them yeah
and john amos got to spend time with him
oh what a lovely human being so many
legends on that yeah and you know john
amos if he wouldn't have done those tv
shows he did there wouldn't be a lot of
the stuff that eddie did
yeah you know he opened it up i mean
john did you know he portrayed a really
a working-class black family before
anyone else did as far as i'm concerned
yeah um but i talked to eddie about he's
going to do his stand-up his plan was to
do dolomite coming to america and then
do a stand-up tour
we were talking i told him he could open
for me any time
and we always laugh we and daddy got
i've always gotten along really i bet
what is your plan then louie are you
going to start doing stuff are you going
to go back to doing stand-up in vegas
yes wow great i know i have a few offers
in vegas but i'm going to do a tour
in minnesota i think i'm going to do
like every city
i've never done in minnesota louie do
you enjoy doing those um those radio
tours i was made for uh show business
when did you know this is what i gotta
do when i just did it on a dare you know
i was never gonna be a comedian no [ __ ]
i did it on the dare my friend jim
my friend jim o'brien and
introduced him to his wife kathy and
they
get married and he said we're at a club
in minnesota a place we used to drink i
said these comedians i don't know i
don't really care for them and he said
oh you think you're so funny why don't
you try it i go i will i went out and
signed up with the guy for the next week
you're kidding i went down i had my mom
was there my dad my sisters and brothers
all my friends
and what
i did a set like
i don't know
three minutes maybe four minutes and you
wrote it that way i wrote it that week
and uh first joke was i can't stay long
in between meals
and
i wrote a bunch of fat jokes and
different things and
worked the crowd even a little it just
was i go oh this this is a fun job oh
and that was uh october 10 1978.
oh my god so you just had the con you
had confidence you had correct i mean
i'm at 10th of eleven you get yeah
enough
you had to find your voice in that
big of a
group i think that i just so i was made
i was a know-it-all as i i thought i
knew everything i know nothing of course
like most entertainers i hated when
google showed up because i was really a
good [ __ ] artist kept proving you
wrong yeah and people go that's not true
i go shut up
that's funny louis we were i was talking
about as i do the show with my brother
we were talking about how
old
uh good he's um we're both uh our grand
we were very close with our grandmother
and she passed away a couple weeks ago
so we're i'm sorry yeah that's her name
jody oh jody i'm so sorry
this one of these emails was from a jody
maybe that was jody saying hi to you oh
she would have loved her do you feel
that did you my brother visited me
on the night of the 22nd he died on the
night of the 22nd
really
vivid it was clearly him i want i was a
it was a whirling dervish of love
and i reached my hand out and it came
towards me
and i i felt completely at peace
and it was gone i just felt so comforted
by it
oh my god and i don't know if i manifest
that myself if i want it
or if it's real but sure it sure look
real to me
uh it's comforting just hearing you say
that because you know any
stuff stories like that have been really
helpful for my mom too now because we
were just so close i i um and each of us
had different
i'm sure you know this all too well i
mean not just that experience but
the morning she died i
whatever we just all had experiences
that felt like she was saying
it's okay and i'm it's okay to and to
let go and
it was definitely my baby brother and
how long was this that was tommy yeah
and how long was this after his passing
17th
the 19th or 2017.
so it was the point and that he died in
17 and this was
february
22nd
wow my bed's right there that's why i'm
in my bed it was in my bed he was right
there he was spinning and i go
this is very pleasant and yet
this is somebody you know i mean
it isn't i knew it was a
it had a personal feeling it was a yeah
it was a human it was a prison it was a
ghost or a spirit or yeah an entity i
don't know and i don't know if i
invented it but i didn't if i did it's a
subconscious invention yeah
and and louie up until that point did
you were you carrying a lot of pain
about wow
you know you get these memories that
show up on your computer
yeah so all those pictures came
an hour before that i looked right at
them and the first one that came up he
was looking right at me
what do you do
yeah you just embrace it and uh
and i i'm glad my brain if it is
manufacturing that
i wish they would bring me some more
people to say hi i know i know my
grandma used to say she was a guest on
the show actually oh how lovely
yeah and um and she i used to i'd record
her a lot because i loved
we just got along really well we were
just good yeah well you're you you were
the favorite
ah between you and your brother
i no no i i'd see her more than they
would only because it was easier for me
to get down i don't have to say it i get
it i can't yeah um you shouldn't say
things like that no no no no i know what
it's like to have something she was i
guess you were her favorite i got to get
some chapstick oh look at this i reach
in my pocket my brother made me this it
sounds like it looked like you were
getting out of here is that crazy well
it's not crazy my brother may used to
send these things to me he made it out
of here what is it exactly
for my chapstick and it's a little thing
it's a little bracelet thing
i keep them in my pocket to remind me of
them oh my gosh you keep something of
your grandma's with you so that you can
have that reminder all the time well you
know she had a tree that she loved i
found little seeds from the tree and i
brought it back i brought them back we
were trying to plant them so i have a
little i have those oh that's something
that's great it's great and how get a
load of get a load of this i haven't
said i like that i love that you gotta
let that in fact get a load of this
jimmy yeah
i hope you're sitting
i hope you're you're sitting down for
this one um
fans of the show of this show uh
they've this has made me it's gonna make
me cry just talking about they they all
um they got together and they bought i
guess you can buy
in in people's honor you can buy them
trees and so they
it's such a lovely thing and she loved
trees
yeah and so they got 420 of them so
she's got like this orchard now
i know where is that in michigan i got
to find out exactly but
it's a good time to thank them too
because i did want to do that publicly
and when you go bring something to your
grandmas to bury in that forest yeah i
want to yeah no it just really meant a
lot to us and she would have been so
tickled she would have been like
you know she had this funny laugh like
kind of like stan laurel that was really
good though that
oh oh she's so cheesy oh you really
loved her oh yeah she you would've yes
what did she like what was her favorite
thing to go and eat
uh she'd make miyaki she was italian she
was from uh abruzzi the southern part of
italy and um she loved pasta
but no restaurants ever made it as good
as you know
i think yeah
you know was that what she would do yeah
and she lived so long that she got to be
really proud of her age and she would
always brag about it to people
she's 104. oh my god yeah yeah
oh congratulations jody yeah i know i
know and then you start thinking they're
out there they're with most of her
friends and family they were they're
gone too so
i'm just hoping she's
having a blast with them and
yeah
did you have a hard time in school i
would imagine you were very popular and
now i was a very shy little little guy
really yeah i'm just imagining the guy
i'm i'm trying
to imagine how then that guy who got up
on stage on the dare from jim i just did
it and then that you weren't you were
overwhelmed
you're making jokes about your weight
yeah i was terrified
but i was once i got up there i was so
comfortable i went oh
right away i went i'm doing this again
yeah because i wanted to write whatever
i didn't do right then that's who i am
oh perfectionist
it came to me it came to me the writing
yeah stories jokes they just they're
there for me
i'm really lucky i'm so lucky
but that sounds like you would have
there was a very fertile environment
well i used to stay up my dad was a
loved he was a jazz musician
he loved doc severance on the tonight
show the trumpet and coronet player
himself
and then i would stay up and watch the
comedian and i said these guys are good
and it was fun and they made me laugh
and who were those guys for you jack
benny bob hope
jackie gleeson
a great comic um
uh
well jonathan winters was a huge
influence oh my gosh your prior was
jackie vernon who's saying like
but timing-wise jack benny and bob hope
and johnny carson they had a giant
influence and all the silly stuff i do
jonathan rickles
johnson winners
jonathan winters what a genius yeah and
so um
you know i liked it but i never thought
oh i could be a comedian
but people did always laugh when i would
talk and i would go you know i'm being
serious
and then they would laugh like that and
then i go people just laugh at me when i
talk they go it's the way you say it and
i go home what did you think that was
and what do you think that is now
looking back is it because you you're so
good with voices and with capturing
people through
the expression the way they they express
themselves do you think it was your
voice as simple as i don't you know i
wish i thought i wish i knew
[Music]
exactly what it is but it's easier for
me
for other people to see me than it is
for me to see me and that's why i think
i could play that part i played i think
i can disappear
yeah and i think i can because i
know my mom so well
i think the empathy that she taught me
to have
i really do care about people where did
you learn that was that from your mom
well how did you learn that and my dad
because we would go to shoppers or we go
to country club market
and do the cart you know full of
groceries that you love can i get the
oreos get the hydraulics louie what do
you think we're
um
we got high drugs too yeah yeah
uh we do it ah pot pies 10 for a dollar
get a billionaire i'll feed you mongols
um
so
we're checking out and my dad would go
put that stuff here on the side
give me a bag i'll put that stuff in
there
on the way home he put that bag in last
on the way homie go go put that at
what's your name's door step there and
knock on the door but don't wait for it
to come just leave the bag of food
oh wow and i said oh my dad's a a human
being
huh that really helped me see my dad a
little differently
wow you know
did you recognize how
special that behavior was in the in the
moment or well obviously because you
know i i mean
i think so but not like not like i'm
talking to you about it yeah you've had
you know probably i said as a little kid
why are you bringing them food i wanted
to get the oreos um
but um
wow and my mom would say no you know
everybody needs help louie
wow you know i mean she literally
invited kids over there she would feed
him and then one woman got in a fight
with her
he's scared my kid's getting fat because
you're feeding them and he's already
eaten
and she goes well he looks a little
peaked to me
and i was just i was just like
she was formidable i mean you know and
then she would say do you want a piece
of cake no
i don't want a piece of cake i'll pick
me my kid
and and i would say my mom is uh
you know when you're a kid you don't get
your dad when you're in trouble you get
your mom she's 10 times tougher
yeah
yeah because god get out of here he's
getting his mom she killed a bat
yesterday
you know those are the where all my
jokes came from the reality of
my perception of
uh this uh less than perfect but
certainly relevant and certainly uh
akin to other people
i was gonna tell you something can i
yeah please you have something to tell a
story and now that you've gone through
this giant loss
you need to
make a piece of art about it and i don't
know what that means but it's in there
and i just felt like i should tell you
that oh yeah i think you're right i
think i mean i wrote my best stuff
after bad situations really because yeah
i opened myself up i just went all right
here it is there it is up until then
before that what was the what did the
material consist of what was your where
did you pull from before you had believe
it or not i i mean i'm unbelievable
right before and after
mostly before i think but right up to
the full moon
sometimes i won't sleep and just write a
whole thing of magic you know like um
stand up or nowadays uh show ideas or
stuff like that you know
possible book stuff mostly just right i
open my heart up i think i'm connected
to some i i think we all are as artists
i think you know when you're in your
groove you know if you're not open if
you're not wide open
what are you waiting for i tell this the
comments you have one story to tell
it's down in inside it's not outside
get in there and lay in that well
and bring some of it up with you
and put it in the light
and see what you can find about yourself
that will help you and help others do
you ever look back at old
old stuff of yours and think oh i hadn't
gotten there yet
and and
yeah i mean you know i always go i love
finding stuff i was doing that when i
was throwing stuff out i go
i found this note that somebody wrote me
louie
i just
it was after a show i just i you just
make me feel better
uh-huh keep doing what you're doing
huh i i said i can't put my wall i'm
gonna put that in my wallet
and
and then i have notebooks and i have
tons of stuff i've been i've been a good
record keeper
and i've recorded a lot of my stuff
throughout the years i have a
lot of
tapes some vhs to high eight
of your family too you've still i have
some of my family stuff
[Music]
i have this great mother's day special
in twin cities media
um
where it's a mother's day show and a
local celebrities and me
we all have our mothers on with them
and it's me and my mom talking it's
really beautiful
from when so shy
1901. no um
i get up i'm sorry yeah uh i think it
was 1980 something
uh-huh and she flew in and i flew in my
sister was there
and she got shy when she was on the
camera and i was such like a i was like
a two-year-old with my mom you'd really
love it
i can send it to you and then you can
put it on the thing when you
oh i would love that
what what what would she say what did
what would she say when you told her i
can't give you the
oh i told you what on the show yeah i
want to hear your mom say like oh mom
they want you to do this thing on oh
well
i'll check my schedule
i go what are you doing oh louie i've
got things going on
i know people i've told people things
i've got to be somewhere i do it all
louie you know that but i think i'll be
able to do it
now
where would we be staying
and would i stay with you
well i get you your own room
okay
and
i go you know mom it'll be fun won't it
of course i gotta get my hair done of
course i don't want to go in there
looking like a rag doll
i go mom you've never learned my mom was
like i never knew
young in my life
as a young kid that my mom got up and
got ready to make breakfast i thought
she just looked like that always i
wasn't that funny yeah she's so sweet
you know she's like a classy woman
yeah
what but she must have been so
proud she must have been so excited
about what it was
i i you know she got to see me on the
tonight show she i took her to the white
house i performed at the white house
with ronald reagan on the reopening of
the
ford theater
uh where we performed i performed tip
o'neal and ronald reagan
and we got to meet at pictures with me
and ron and nancy
and her and ron and nancy oh she's very
proud very proud
very uh lovely so in my book hey mom
i gotta read it
you're gonna really love hey mom
especially now
yeah i encourage you guys out there to
contact your mom mother's day is not
that far away yeah but to uh spend some
time with her on a regular basis and
become her friend
or your dad
and find out
you know don't think it's gonna all come
tumbling out the first time you get
together
gotta you know they're not gonna just
spill the beans you're gonna have to pay
for it a little bit
they'll put up with what they want but
just remember this they have every story
that you need from them to complete your
story and your puzzle
and your life did that take you a while
to learn that was that something that
you've been doing your whole life
i wrote the books both posthumously
you know after they were gone so i've
i'm so pissed off at myself for not
being a nicer son
and i'm more generous with my time and
thinking that i'd have a lot of time to
spend with them and they'd be here
forever what an idiot
and so i say to you
not for me
and not for them but for you
why not it's true there's a reason we
call the show life is short it's just a
sentiment that i love
saying i didn't even know that was the
name of your show yes well and you're
such a fan of the show i really said
that i'm a fan of you i'm kidding
when they told me the name i looked it
up and i saw you and i go yeah he's
great ah no no i was kidding i i didn't
is it called lifeless shorts yeah yeah
it's called life is short
and that funny ah you think they'd be 15
minute interviews then he was supposed
to
i'm just teasing uh in 10 10 of those in
a row life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
uh really quick we have like a lightning
round what is lou do you use emojis when
you text
no i don't have emojis on my phone on
purpose no oh really on purpose
i just go i can't get into this whole
thing i don't know what this one means
even if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you want to
play
in basketball basketball
the timberwolves fans
no
the lakers but oh you're wearing that he
just
plopped down at timberwolves yeah well
i'm a fan you know i love my
hometown yeah um they were the
minneapolis lakers originally so uh oh
yeah that's right it makes more sense
yeah there are no lakes in l.a uh
right uh but a lot of timberwolves also
tennis i would i think i could have been
a great tennis player oh you know
because i'm very competitive and
tennis is all about you you and so you
know i'm an ego maniacal person
so you must be fun to play games with to
play uh like a pictionary or something
uh
they have to be like it has to be
charades
i think playing cards like uh
you know uh
hearts and spades and
and games that
are really hard to win and you have to
count on your partner and i like those
kind of things i like those
things
you know what
would your mom play any games any board
games any did she do anything social
what do we do with this now what is this
oh why turn it over
what um well we could play crazy eights
i've played that haven't i louie yes
i love you mom
or ella anderson keep it in mind nora
aura aura
oh wow great dance right yeah
it means light i think it's a jewish
name yeah i mean it means light ah
well her aura is all around you yeah um
and zella i think is yiddish but i'm not
sure about anything anymore wow and and
wow does she come from a big family
no uh three i think it was her brother
and two sisters maybe three sisters
huh named her brothers my middle name
perry is
named after her brother perry louis
perry lewis perry my dad was lewis
william anderson oh wow
i knew i didn't know his name was louie
for years no really everybody called him
andy
oh weird
andy anderson wow yeah
and i thought his name was andy
that's so fanny andy anderson
was he around louis to see your success
and see you get some he
he was there the first night i did a
show all right and he had a stroke the
next day you're kidding so i always felt
so terribly guilty but my dad then went
on to have 20 or 30 strokes he was a
really tough guy oh my coverage from all
of them
1979.
so he got to see a little bed he carried
a picture of me by his bed
and he said you'll make it louie ah oh
wow wait so within a
he had 20 or 30 strokes not after that
stroke throughout his
life because i think that was his first
stroke to be honest holy [ __ ] that means
he has art of his really bad health
stuff uh in a year maybe it was two
years it might have been two years i
mean maybe 20 or 30 is an exaggeration
but
i would get a call that to come to the
hospital i think this is it oh my god
yeah because hey can you give me a
cigarette i go i cannot give you a
cigarette oh my god
uh if you could have won snack food for
the rest of your life desert island
snack food
what would it be what is your go-to is
it snack food yeah you're sick you're
watching tv and you're just like popping
what caramel corn with chocolate and
nuts and caramel and chocolate chocolate
you know how they make that new caramel
corn that's on steroids
yeah have you had that yeah what it what
is is it asteroid yeah it's like the
popcorn is it gets drowned out by all
these other exciting things so that or
just you know it could be a mix of
popcorn cheese caramel corn and regular
corn i guess if i pick one thing because
that could be
kind of filling in food like uh-huh um
are you are you a popcorn guy at the
movies god i miss going in the room yeah
only at the movies i would never buy
popcorn otherwise probably it's volume
that doesn't kill you yes like you could
eat a big thing of that
big diet coke on the side
right yeah i always pour raisinettes in
the popcorn oh weird
yeah i'm a weirdo yeah um yeah
or something used to be chocolate
peanuts but then i went i think i feel
like the reason that's better oh goobers
yeah you know what i like also peanut m
m's are good in the pool oh that's my
brother's favorite that's his go-to he
said it's like cam yeah but now louie
can you imagine how awful that's
disgusting it sounds just
touching eating things with your hands
in public and i still would do it oh
really
all right
um
yeah yeah shaking hands something about
reaching into that thing
and being able not to spill it and get
all that
in your mouth and have a sip of the
drink
and just go oh yeah i'm an addict huh
i'm a food addict baby
yeah um if if well it's too much to talk
about that there there are all these
doors that keep opening i wanna i wanna
go sorry well we'll do it again i
promise you okay all right i'm looking
forward to it uh
part d so maybe i should say something
what's your go-to karaoke song
i keep a close watch on this heart of
mine
okay i walk the line i keep my eyes wide
open all the time
um and who was your first celebrity
crush if you had one when you were
growing up
i think it was
see let's see i've been 1905. uh-huh
i'm trying to think of like growing up
what things i had mm-hmm
yeah what would it be it would be the
fifth uh
your 50s 60s i think the first movie i
saw and that kind of stuff were you a
fan show
yeah did you what did you were you a lot
you were allowed to watch tv you were a
lot you yeah we were allowed to watch
i'm trying to think that's a really
great question how about if we answer
that one on the next one we'll do that
on the next one um if and if you had to
get a tattoo i don't know if you have
tattoos what would you get
no um
another belly button
ah
if i got a tattoo
peace love and happiness
or
um on your lower back
ouch on your face wow
if i got another tattoo a pie i probably
do uh um
just love just a heart love i probably
do love ah that's funny you know that's
the tattoo i got once uh with drew she
and she we we got a stick and poke oh
did you from this this musician who was
we were all drunk and um
you know like a problem like guys on
netflix does it
yeah
or or hey which one are you i'm sick
i'm poke
that's the animated show louis that's if
all right i love you if life with louis
doesn't go um
which i really hope it does uh what is
your favorite fruit
well
i just had cantaloupe today which i it's
hit or miss with cantaloupe yes it
really is
but if you get a sweet cantaloupe
i'm not eating half of it yeah all of it
um
uh let's see but my favorite fruit that
i eat the most of would be an apple
probably in an or an orange
because we had those are our
predominant that you know those were the
things we could have oh in growing up
yeah like we could have apples because
there was trees that we could sell the
apples off of sure
and then oranges were plentiful
and so
yeah i love great orange like i
i have you know replaced eating sweets
before i go to bed by with an orange or
two oh oh oh oh oh huh it's funny louis
because i was thinking about my grandma
the morning i woke up um when my mom
called me she had passed away uh
when
i always thought about when i thought
about my grandma i i thought about
fruit fresh citrus fruit
because we'd go visit her in florida and
i i thought it was so cool that she
would get these fresh grapefruits and
whatever cut them up and i'd never
forget thinking how great that was that
she could you just get them off the tree
and
and i woke up i kid you not i woke up in
a um
i had a camper van that i just bought
and i was driving across the country and
i woke up in this uh citrus grove i
never i just slept there the night
before that was so beautiful yeah
yeah and did you then after you heard
that did you go get a piece of that
citrus um
no i cried i i
i made the obvious connection i'm glad
you cried a lot yeah i would be dead a
lot yeah yo oh don't worry no that's
good though i mean yeah i encourage
people like every day
you should get some joy
you should laugh
you should think
you should be brought to tears every day
if you're not brought to tears every day
you're stuffing something down oh
i mean i could cry
all any time
and not it doesn't have to be but you
should be brought to tears
yeah you should with these you got to
keep that stuff working
yeah
um what movie would you recommend if you
needed a good cry and is just like oh
this all if if you don't cry during such
and such you are um maybe incapable of
crying
uh
terms of endearment
oh
it's funny for a second
terminator
is that as a second choice
is that the one with uh
deborah deborah
uh yeah and uh what's her name uh
no it's the other one they incar
reincarnated uh
great actress she was in uh oh oh oh
shirley maclaine yeah yeah and jeff
daniels yes yeah what
yeah i know this husband who's not
doesn't quite know what to do and you
know i'm embarrassed to say this louie
i've never
i've never seen it oh wow i know i know
it's a classic but uh yeah of course you
know a lot of people haven't seen movies
you know that's
and then i guess
for a comedy i would say being there oh
i love being there you know it's
probably one of the best
yeah
it surely is in that too
yeah oh
but in terms of endearment i was
devastated
i was crying like a baby in there yeah
um uh we're almost done uh who would you
want to play you in your biopic
um
well there's a really great actor
who's uh really a comedian too and he
played
did you watch baskets yes yeah so
do you know the guy who played the
juggalo in arby's
oh yeah a heavier version there was a
yeah there was a kid who couldn't do it
in the third season uh-huh so this kid
came in
tommy snyder oh yeah
yeah he's a really
great he's in a lot of different things
yes i recognize him you know who he is
yeah he has a
he has a
you know he would be great
he has an element that you know would be
great
i love that whole
sublime yeah the juggalos thing um
uh okay dogs are cats do you prefer
boy it's almost of equal deal oh really
okay i have anybody else's dogs and my
cat oh interesting yeah
right do you get does that make sense
yeah sure how are you
oh get over here you have to clean up
the [ __ ] yeah well i just i mean you
know i'm not a good
pet owner because
i'm gone a lot when i'm traveling
sure and also
oh yeah i better feed that thing
um well god i love animals and i hate
that you know people are that we have so
much cruelty out there for every living
thing
yeah well that's why it's nice that
someone like you thank god has a
a platform and can make the world a
better place and well you know like this
is a good thing we should talk about in
the next one yeah how do we all do it
daily
that should be our next thing okay cuz
i'd really like to investigate the idea
of how do you justin how do i
how does your brother how does dick
honestly
he's really into facebook who is the
person that works with you
is that michelle yeah we call her miesha
those are the exact lyrics yeah
yeah anyway
um
yeah we should do that but yeah
and okay i'm writing it down so
understanding about stuff uh louie uh
you have my word and i'm lucky that i
got to do this with you this is really
good for my heart i feel better likewise
i i i
it's so great that we can talk our way
out of it all i know
isn't it
yeah and
and connect with somebody especially now
i'm like i think there's a part of me
too that is very starved for um
a really nice warm you're a hugger right
yeah i am you yeah yes and so huggers
are suffering a lot yes isn't that funny
you know you could do this they had that
thing where they if you do this louie's
hugging himself this is uh this is oh no
your body feels
your psyche oh really represent we will
feel this hug
oh no kidding
just do like that and
and then
as my mom would do she would
when things weren't going exactly how
she wanted them to
her hands would you know like whenever i
was doing a show about
and my dad had died
and i would talk about her my mom would
go
she missed some dress
really missed my dad oh
even though he was a jerk to her but
he's been amazed it was her jerk so yeah
my mom was so strong
that my dad
who was a drunk
you know alcoholic i shouldn't call him
a drunk he was not just a but he could
really get drunk and uh what was his
drink of choice
whatever yeah
um i think it varied actually whatever
was you know i it was a true alcoholic
because yeah ever was available yeah so
um
he quit drinking when he was 69.
wow and my mom turned to me and said i
told you he'd quit
and i think that
i think that
i know i i i didn't know that until
later
what a statement that was yeah that she
hung in there with him she and he quit
wow yeah
what prompted him to quit
i think he got a you know a dui or
something oh okay punch the neighbor
would she ever
what was her role in that did she ever
try to get him to quit i mean were
people able to do that or i guess if you
want to quit you're going to quit but i
think anybody who's married to an addict
tries to get them to quit yeah well yeah
you know
the addicts ride is a singular thing
unfortunately and it's so hard to reach
them
and what i say about addicts is
i hope they don't die before they can
get off it yeah
yeah the very low percentage of people
who don't
right who can quit
and then to quit for a long time and to
stay off it is really hard and how long
and imagine that this has been horrible
yeah
for people who are out oh my god yeah
about 10 years 79 when he died or 80 i
don't know when he i keep
somebody told me it was 80 i go i think
it's 79. wow
and how old was aura
she was 77 she was younger than my dad
wow wow
well i feel like louie that she was the
um
i feel like she was here and i feel like
you're your grandma was here yeah me too
cody was here because why i i mean you
citrus came up yeah yeah and jody and
then whatever did i mention cantaloupe
and the fruit and the oh i heard you say
jody too you were reading your text and
i was like oh isn't that funny
um and that jody never comes up in a
text from me oh that's a rare
name i didn't say the rest of the name
because i'm only like yeah private stuff
yeah you read my name on the thing yeah
yeah sorry it's a great name though i do
if i kids i i think i i would like one
of them to be a jody
um
yeah who was your last guest
uh today was uh adam brody do you know
adam yeah
no i don't know the last one the last
one that was
after yes
adam was in a show called the oc and um
oh yeah which one is he in there he was
um
i love the oc
seth
seth was that a character
hey you know you never thought
well no it was a little
after my um
i know him through other movies and
stuff that you might like kevin smith we
both do a bunch of those movies with
kevin and um
i'm trying to think what else he's in uh
i'll look it up
oh you know he's promoting that movie um
a promising young woman which is great
if you haven't seen it oh yeah
it looks really good but it looks great
yeah yeah but i mean you know i got my
sad i'll watch that stuff i just
finished watching call my agent which is
one of the best i never like reading
subtitles
i watched all four seasons it's so
brilliant call my asian
h agent no no no yeah no i know okay oh
you would be
funny call my agent
yeah i haven't heard of that one
yeah it's french it's in paris oh wow
it's so fantastic okay
i need some you'll love it you'll love
it the characters the agents the actors
it's our lives but
and done in a different way but it's
beautiful okay okay you'll love every
bit of it uh do you love waiting for
goffman the movie waiting for guffman
yeah i bet gorky
yeah
oh he's mike michael hitchcock oh my god
i love michael there's scott me too god
and you just do everything there is to
do
i love that movie i do too
there are things that michael does in
that that like i'm thinking of just when
when he walks by after he's complimented
him after he's seen the show red white
or blane and he's like you're just you
know whatever he pays him a compliment
and then the the camera's on
christopher guess but you just see
michael looking after him you know just
staring him down in the background it's
so good
you know
it's a beautiful movie yeah because of
that movie
there's lots of movies like that now yes
in fact it's a reference when you're
pitching stuff it's kind of like guffman
and roughman
uh-huh well baskets is yeah well i hope
people do i feel like baskets was ahead
of its time so yeah well it's brilliant
i i um i want to go back and re-watch it
now and uh i can't wait to read your
stuff and i'm rooting for life with
louie and i'm just rooting for you
because i'm rooting for you yeah i
really love to help personally yeah hey
uh
keep me uh i'll have uh i'll figure out
to follow follow me i'll follow you
follow you and then i'll send you my
info on that i would love it i would
cover it i'll get back
oh yeah okay all right i can't wait to
do it again i can't wait uh thank you
all right thank you so much for being so
kind likewise
oh
so that happened
oh
it's too your voice is too low two oh it
is uh that's part of the thing like when
he i noticed that his his voice is
naturally pitched a bit higher yeah
which made it easier for him to play his
yeah i like when he said i don't want to
change my voice and they're like yeah
yeah because it still kind of works just
as it is it's brilliant but i noticed it
specifically when he did
the he the beefs and butt head
impression he's like i love mike judge
he's like and he did an impression of i
think butthead he was like uh yeah
that's pretty cool but i it's like oh
your voice is just way too high yeah
you're like dude
that's
more down here yeah uh that's yeah
because mike's voice is pitch natural oh
yeah it's kind of like this and yeah
louie up here well that's why he's so
good at
excuse me he's so good at animating at
voices
but he's do he's good at like that when
he did little louie he was great it was
really good yeah i hope they do bring
that back me too and i hope he stays
true to his word and offers you a
partner oh that'd be great i know i uh
the show i'm doing on netflix now not an
ad f is for family we're in our last
season and i'm getting a little bit
a little squirrely wanting to do more
animated stuff uh so louis i bet he's
listening
you think yeah i bet you you guys really
hit it off we did in fact you're friends
now we are fair to say it is very fair
and he um
texted me the next day wanted to talk he
said he had something to talk about and
um
i was like oh i'll call you later this
afternoon and i and i failed to do so
because christian and i had been away uh
with margaret on a very fun vacation it
was so fun in fact that we kept um
delaying our return to uh non-vacation
and uh so all this work piled up work
but like podcast stuff fun work but
still it just counts
i know it's our work i know it's not i'm
not digging ditches but it's yeah uh
piled up nothing wrong with digging
ditches justin no i didn't i'm saying
it's more impressive anyway sorry um
and it piled up so we had uh stuff to do
and i just i just got busy and i forgot
to
call him back i forgot i just felt like
oh it's late whatever i was watching the
bachelor and okay there we go i'm told i
had to catch up on the bachelor there's
a lot to catch up on bachelor work yeah
okay
um and then the next day i got a text
from him and he said uh
he said oh why do you not like me now it
was something like like i had i you know
went back on my word and i felt
immediately terrible and i called him
right away don't not call louie i know i
know so i did and uh he wasn't really
mad he was just being playful playful
he's a playful person he sure is and i
and we had a great talk and um and he
said you know we got to do i would love
to you kept planning the second
he's like when i come back we're gonna
talk we'll cover these well there's too
much yeah there's too much to talk to
him and he's also the kind of person
that like you don't have to plan
a a conversation with christian does the
research for the show and thank you for
that and you're always like giving me
good things to talk about but um
but in this case it was like it could
have just been the most like
certain people
certain people you can just amorphous
chit chat with yes you know and like
very easily oh he's a great chit chatter
well i think in part because he's
someone who is like
he's a comedian and i think i have this
preconceived notion of comedians which
isn't fair that they're that they tend
to be cynical and kind of dark i know so
he
really surprised me in this episode that
he is both really funny
but also
not the slightest bit cynical or jaded
or dark he's like could not be more
um open-hearted i know and empathetic
and
we in fact i've always fancied myself
to be not those things to dark or like
jaded those things but i he has an even
um you know more acute awareness of that
kind of stuff of cynicism and so
whenever i'd veer there or i'd say
something that like was potentially
nasty or snarky he either he just would
very deliberately not pick up the ball i
noticed i i don't know if you you got
that impression we may have cut some of
that stuff out but he refused to like go
there he was very there's something very
kind like compassionate about him and i
don't know if i communicated this to him
or if
you're aware of this but like
zach alfinakis is the same way oh really
yeah people people might be surprised to
hear that but um because you know of his
persona or like how he's the roles he's
played but he is an incredibly like open
heart like very sensitive sensitive yes
yes good word very sensitive person
let's hope to others hopefully future
guests of the show i know i got a i know
um yeah he and it's i think
with a lot of people who have had really
difficult
childhoods and and traumatic experiences
it um
it i think it
i don't know if it often leads to this
level of introspection but
i think
it's it kind of lays the groundwork for
possibly being able to get that
introspective you know what i mean like
i think because he had so many difficult
experiences growing up it um
it caused him to really force you to
examine and examine yourself and examine
uh
your parents and yeah and he's done
clearly done so much work and has
thought so deeply about this stuff well
take this it's impressive it's like it
is it's led to a real wisdom yeah and
and i feel like an evolution of
character yeah
of course i didn't know him before this
i'm just meeting him for the first time
but he strikes me as someone who is
really is really evolved um
i take this with a big grain of salt uh
like non-doc i don't have i've never
taken even a psychology course i don't
think maybe one-on-one but i wonder if
it's if you have such an obviously like
you said traumatic
childhood um i wonder if it's
if if if there's just a greater
um
need there's a greater need but also
like uh
it's it's easier to unpack it's there's
i don't know what i'm trying to say
whereas if there's more of an impetus
impetus to work on yourself yes yeah
whereas like if you had i mean everyone
has trauma everyone's got stuff from
their past but if it was a little bit
more subtle or
not quite as obvious as it is in in
louie's case i wonder
i think
that's what that's what i was trying to
get at yeah um i i barely got it
well neither of us really got it
we're not qualified to get at it but i i
suspect that when you're forced to
um like face the situation
it is uh it doesn't make it easier but
it makes it maybe easier to start the
process because
the issues are so deep and strong it's
so obvious that you can point to a clear
thing he was an alcoholic he neglected
us you know we're talking about
i just i can't believe i'm making this
transition or attempting to but the
bachelor we just saw if you watching the
bachelor this year matt james who is the
bachelor um
i it was one of the most dramatic things
i've ever seen
probably the most dramatic they've ever
seen on the show with his dad yeah he
could oh by i think far and away in 20
years of that show it's like who's the
most intense ugh moving scene i've ever
seen so for those the few of you who
haven't seen it he confronted his father
who
left the family when he was young and
he did
the bachelor confronted him matt and he
did it in such a an impressive uh
measured way i mean it was emotional but
he was communicating himself his his
feelings in a very effective um and it
led to us
like a wonderful reconciliation between
them yeah so moving and um
and yeah i mean i was like
i've never seen anything like that on
the show and it was so impressive that
he was able to do that uh yeah and to do
it on cameras so and that the father i
mean it was just beautiful anyway why
are we talking louie anderson well well
i think because it was an obvious trauma
that he went through yeah he just has
such a big heart in the way he was
talking to about grandma and his and uh
yeah and his own brother who made me
emotional that made me yeah really feel
connected
and it also
struck a chord with me because when he
was talking about seeing his brother
after he had passed away and he had this
experience where
you know he he saw him and he's like you
know whether my brain just concocted
that yeah or not or if it was real who
knows
um
but it reminded me of
you know uh listeners of the show know
that our grandma recently passed away
and and and i've
i think we've all had experiences in the
last
month since it happened where we've
really felt her presence and um i don't
know if it's true or not i obviously we
all want that to be true but um even if
it's not there's something really
powerful about
feeling that you know feeling connected
to someone and
whether it's like the orange grove you
talked about or anything you know it's
it's nice to feel connected to someone
however you can and and i'm more
inclined to believe somebody who like
louis who allows for the possibility
that it was just a figment of his
imagining or or you know you know it
might have been just this but there's
something more compelling about somebody
who because that's more
similar i guess to how i think more
honest more honest yeah and instead of
saying like no no it was definitely
you know because he said even he said
i'm paraphrasing but he said
even if my brain
did concoct me yeah yeah i i enjoyed it
and i hope it keeps you know yeah
showing me more of that yeah because
even if it's not true it's still it
still felt really nice to see him right
and uh that's how i feel too yeah we've
had those like you said experience we've
also this is the first time we've
christian i've talked to have been
talking about this in our private lives
but it's our first real experience with
this kind of loss like a a a very
profound loss and i mean we've been
lucky in that sense that we've gone this
long without having to deal with it um
i know that's rare but uh louis
having so many siblings and being so
close to his family i mean when he said
that it really just
punched me in the gut when he said oh no
there are only like two of his siblings
left which means he's had to deal with
uh
he's just very familiar with with loss
like that and it's
uh and and it hasn't doesn't seem to
have beaten him down in any way i mean
he still seems quite
positive and well i think he's
it's made him more uh just that much
more empathetic and uh compassionate
about someone else's pain and struggle
and he
i i really felt it like listening to him
concerned
with you this person he just met yeah
and your feelings and your grief
uh
that's a pretty rare thing yeah you know
someone who has that level of
uh empathy we should say one more thing
about this very important thing
the group the facebook group that um the
shorties the shorties yeah um two very
kind shorties uh robin and izzy they
started this um
this
push to to get um trees planted in
grandma's name in grandma's honor a push
push is not the right word they started
they did a thing yeah so they did a
thing and um
they solicited contributions from people
fans of the show who have who really
fans of grandma jody who um
who wanted to contribute something in
her name and what they ended up doing
was
um
buying
420
trees to be replanted in um
in a place that needs trees planted in
michigan
and they also
um
sent
a they compiled a bunch of messages
little short notes
from people who
were moved by grandma jody in some way
and they compiled them into one document
and
sent them to us and uh
it's just such a it was such a moving
kind uh thing for them to do and talk
about keeping somebody's oh my god alive
and keeping somebody's memory alive i
mean speaking of someone who is like has
such a big heart like louis anderson i
think so often we're
we're just inundated
by negativity in our culture and you
know the news and politics and and
there's so much anger and and
divisiveness and so when something like
this happens when a group of strangers
to us
does something
this kind and generous and loving it's
such a
like wonderful reminder that people are
good and and people are capable of
genuine
kindness and goodness and and louis
reminded me of that and all
of you shorties have reminded us of that
too yeah it's meant um and we're gonna
share share with our mom when she's
i don't think she's ready to
read these notes yet but one day she
will be and i know i know she's going to
be really really touched by all your
messages as well and i'm thinking of how
touched grandma would be and like she'd
be embarrassed kind of she'd be like oh
sh it'd be a combination of like uh
she's she'd be proud that she people
responded that way but also she'd she
wouldn't want to show it so she'd sort
of feign like oh geez um
so
thank you so much for that uh
that would that really i mean that's an
understatement to say it means a lot
and to know that we have people
listening to the show
uh people who have gravitated toward the
show who have such uh kind hearts that's
um it makes me that much prouder and
happier to be doing this show you know
let's read a letter okay um
i'm gonna reach behind me
to get the letter from our i'm so proud
we have a
we have a printer now very exciting you
know we're really moving up in the world
yeah in our podcast studio
uh okay this is from allison reed very
interesting spelling for alison
oh i've i thought i'd seen every
spelling
uh this is a l y s o n ali sun huh
ali sun how do you spell reed r-e-e-d oh
i like margaret yeah yeah
shout out
shout out to margaret and the reed clan
um i hope kt and patrick are listening
i do too yeah they better be by the way
patrick and katie if you're listening
just uh text us um an emoji of a banana
a banana
yeah okay that'll be a good test
we better get that text uh here's back
to allison alison
hey all this is an appreciation email
for your podcast i first started
listening to life is short last year in
fact
it was while i was listening to the
podcast for the first time while out on
a hiking trail taking in the great
outdoors that some random [ __ ] tried
to assault me jesus
i know this
she says i know this just took a grim
turn but i promise it gets better wow oh
my god
i had the lena dunham episode playing in
my earbuds one minute i'm happy as can
be getting some sun and fresh air after
being cooped up inside all day due to
the covid lockdown the next minute i'm
sprinting as hard as i can to get away
from this [ __ ] and find help while
simultaneously listening to dunham talk
about how turned on she gets when
watching hockey
that's really what a crazy juxtaposition
i avoided revisiting this podcast for
quite a while
i thought that by association listening
to more of life is short would stir up
some of the trauma from that day much
like the way you can hear a song that
you so strongly associate with a
specific memory and have an instant
visceral reaction to it yeah that makes
sense anyways and then she said anyway
i avoided this podcast like the plague
but then one day i thought [ __ ] it i'm
not gonna let this random [ __ ] take
away my ability to enjoy something so
simple like listening to a recorded
conversation between strangers that
might somehow make me feel a little less
lonely during this crazy time
fast forward a few months okay maybe a
few weeks i'm all caught up now with
every episode i especially love this
weeks with amanda knox
i was nine years old when meredith
kircher was murdered and remember
watching the news coverage very vividly
as a kid i couldn't truly grasp the
gravity of all the misjustice that was
occurring but as i've grown so has my
understanding as well as my admiration
for knox
i really enjoyed listening to your
conversation oh thank you alison yeah um
been good and getting a lot of good
feedback from that in fact i just got a
dm uh
from somebody that that we follow each
other on instagram and they said um you
know i
i actually thought she was
guilty like i didn't know that she
wasn't even
famous i mean yeah so a lot of people
it's nice that you changed
or she changed yeah well just one person
it's mine i know i know that's what i
thought i wanted to promise
but i didn't want her to feel like oh
who else out there is thinks i did this
anyway i didn't but if she's listening
hopefully a man is listening uh as it
turns out your podcast has ended up back
to the letter as it turns out your
podcast has ended up bringing me a lot
of joy this year so i just wanted to say
thanks to you all take care al
oh man cool so cool thank you and
god i hope i'm glad you're okay from
that trauma because whatever yeah that's
scary scary and i'm glad you're not on a
hike i'm glad you weren't triggered by
listening again i know because that is i
that it makes perfect sense that that
could happen
you know yeah i had a very i've talked
about this thing when i got kind of
kidnapped but i that happened when i was
on dax's podcast he talked about that
yeah
um
shout out to dax i wonder if tax is
listed i'm getting very insecure about
who's listening
um
but that happened at a uh one of the i
mean every town has a an irish pub you
know one of those like mcswiggens or
mcswirlies and um
i i i get a little
squirrely now when i go and make
squirrels specifically irish pubs yeah
nothing against irish people oh no
but uh well saint patrick's day is
tomorrow oh that's right yeah well
okay well this is what a way to
celebrate every st patrick's day growing
up we i remember we would have
our mom would make an a traditional
irish yeah meal and it was corned beef
and cabbage
and i loved it so much you put some
mustard on on the corn beef you both
have to have memories of your mother
cooking cabbage on st patrick's day it
was so delicious and i thought
why why do we only do this once a year i
know you have this like once a month
well i think that about ham too i think
that about thanksgiving too yeah i know
a lot of work goes into it so it's like
you're watching this every thursday yeah
all
right
once a year like some of that food
it's like let's let's do this again no
let's not wait till next thanksgiving my
next st patrick's day well shout out to
the firehouse deli there's a uh place in
fairfax
yeah they have a sandwich called the
thanksgiving sandwich yeah my favorite
sandwich yeah and i always thought it
was weird that you'd order it like well
it's not and i subscribed to that uh
that way of thing the traditional real
traditionalist growth growth yes um
yeah so thanks again to allison the only
disappointing thing about this letter
what do you think i'm gonna say no would
you rather yeah
i know but it's nice to change it up
whoa oh really yeah i thought you were
would you rather tradition this like
also we've been we've been talking so
long
that's true would you rather right now
would extend the show too long i think
that way too okay yeah good point um so
anyway thank you alice alison and al you
know i like calling i'm glad that she
called herself al you can call her al
yeah
because allison is also three syllables
yeah son um and al is great and uh
that makes me that's triggers good
memories of a nice song you can call me
how yeah great song uh you know we have
to wrap it up don't you yeah and i'm
stalling because i like doing the show i
want to keep it going all right well
there's always next week that's true so
thanks alison and louis and thank you
again to the shorties
for their beautiful tribute and um
it means the world to us it really does
and uh can't cannot thank you enough
honestly and on behalf of grandma i feel
like i can thank people on behalf of her
she would uh she probably is um i i bet
she's listening i hope so so uh to
everyone to all you shorties thank you
for your kindness and to louie for his
and allison thanks to everyone and we'll
talk to you next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life short is hosted by me justin long
it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long another producer on this
one happens to be megan monaco senior
producer on this particular one in all
particulars are michelle
audio engineering sergio enriquez also
when it comes to executive producing who
gets their hands on this one but none
other than marshall louie
and all of this is done under the banner
of wondering
[Music]
but it but um but if tylenol is bad it's
just not going to be effective it won't
work exactly or if this is bad it'll
taste disgusting that's the thing i
don't think twizzlers after a month of
their final day is disgusting really
what do you mean
yeah a little hard
it won't be i don't mind buzzers that
are hard you just have to suck on them
longer
you know
i don't mind that i kind of like that
process of when they're kind of like
rubbery i wonder what now i wonder they
don't get moldy do you want do you want
to have one why not i'm curious
and uh would you have one for ten
dollars yes
i owe them for free maybe
oh come on
oh
feels right it smells like a twizzler
it's elastic just by the way this is not
old it's a perfectly sane poutine oh
that's the best
oh you're not crazy
it's delicious
there's nothing wrong with it really
they're expired expired tweezers
you